Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon.
Die Leute sehen, dass wir sitzen.
Ja, manche sehen, dass wir sitzen. Manche hören uns ja auch nur. Alles ist möglich. Wir wollen heute noch über Cancel Culture sprechen und man denkt so, oh Gott, nicht die auch noch.
Wie für dich gecancelt? Nein. Ist es wieder ein persönliches Interesse?
Also ich sage mal so, ich kann nicht so leicht gecancelt werden wie andere und damit sind wir schon fast beim Thema. Denn es ist ja so, dass wir verschiedene Formen von Cancel Culture diskutieren müssen und diese linksliberale Aussage, die fast jetzt so eine Art Dogma geworden ist. Es gibt keine Cancel Culture. Das wird ja immer vor sich her gesagt. Dieses Dogma scheint ja doch sehr brüchig zu werden, wenn man so schaut, was passiert. Und ich habe diesem Dogma auch nie Glauben geschenkt. Warum kann ich nicht so leicht gecancelt werden? Zum Beispiel, weil ich keinen Arbeitgeber habe, der mich canceln könnte. Darüber müssen wir mich heute auch sprechen. Ich finde es übrigens interessant. Manchmal bekommt man ja E-Mails mit darüber, dass Stefan, also du, in einem Podcast, nicht mit mir, sondern in einem anderen Podcast oder irgendwo oder bei Twitter irgendwas gesagt hast, von dem man annimmt, dass ich dem nicht zustimmen würde.
Und wie findest du das? Wie behältst du dich da?
Und das wird mir dann gesagt. Und ich reagiere gar nicht darauf, weil ich ja, wenn du was hier im Podcast sagst, nämlich nicht zustimme, widersprechen kann. Aber ich bin ja nicht dein Papa, dass ich jetzt sage, hör mal, du hast aber vor zwei Wochen zu Tilo das und das gesagt. Das finde ich aber gar nicht gut.
Aber üblicherweise finden wir immer gut, was ich im Offer-Podcast sage.
Bestimmt. Da kann ja wohl keiner was dagegen haben. Da sieht man schon so ein bisschen, ob ich da mal so einen Ordnungsruf machen könnte. Also so ist ein gewisser Wunsch, glaube ich, da. Und das ist aber nicht Cancel Culture oder sonst irgendwas. Was mir aber auffällt, ist, dass wir immer mehr jetzt erleben, dass Arbeitgeber verlinkt werden. Das heißt, jemand postet etwas bei Twitter, ist Journalist, postet zum Beispiel einen Artikel über die Proteste an der Columbia-Universität. Der kann in die eine oder andere Richtung gehen. Der kann entweder behaupten, da sind nur Antisemiten, die demonstrieren. Oder der kann behaupten, hier wird die Meinungsfreiheit verteidigt und die Proteste sind absolut gerechtfertigt. Was auch immer dieser Artikel aussagt. Sofort gibt es ja Leute, die das anders sehen. Und dann wird der Arbeitgeber verlinkt, dass man sagt, lieber FAZ, habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, was euer Autor hier geteilt hat. Lieber Spiegel, habt ihr gesehen. Liebes öffentlich-rechtlich.
Na ja, das sind ja wenigstens noch publizistische Arbeitgeber.
Genau, aber auch hier finde ich es schon interessant, dass man also versucht, jetzt nicht in einen Diskurs einzutreten, bei dem man sagt, wir streiten darüber oder wir sind unterschiedlicher Meinung. Oder ich verachte deine Meinung. Auch das ist ja eine Aussage, die man treffen kann. Aber dass man schon sagt, na ja, also wenn der das gepostet hat, wenn er das retweetet hat, dann soll das auch eine Konsequenz haben. Und diese Konsequenz kann natürlich nur eine finanzielle sein. Und darum geht es ja bei der Cancel-Kasche, dass man also Leute cancelt und das hat finanzielle Konsequenzen für sie, dass sie dadurch einen Einfluss an Stimme verlieren, weil sie sich nicht mehr ausdrücken können. Und dann wird immer gesagt, ja, aber es gibt ja sehr viele, die gecancelt wurden und die sind trotzdem enorm reich geworden. Und ja, natürlich, es gibt ja auch so etwas wie Gegenöffentlichkeit oder so. Und da gibt es dann Leute, die kommen aus einem öffentlichen, rechtlichen System oder so raus und werden dann plötzlich als das Opfer von Cancel Culture die neuen Erfolgsgaranten oder so etwas. Das kann alles sein. Ich glaube nur, dass diese neue Kultur, dass man hier nicht etwas kritisiert, sondern dass man denunziert. Dass man sagt, hier muss aber jetzt eigentlich mal der Arbeitgeber durchgreifen. Dass das etwas ist, was jetzt stark zugenommen hat in den letzten, ich würde sagen, drei, vier Jahren.
Wir können das ja systematisieren. Wir haben ja Aufklärungen dafür bekommen, hier im Salon selbst. Ich erinnere an Steffen M und sein Buch Triggerpunkte mit der Argumentation der Arenen, die man nicht verwechseln sollte. Ansonsten begibt man sich auf einen Holzweg. Der kann durchaus erfolgreich sein in der Sache, die man verfolgt. Aber man würde sich dann im kleinen Rahmen nicht besser anstellen als im großen Rahmen, wo wir es kritisieren. Wenn zum Beispiel die Demokratie populistisch untergraben wird oder wie auch immer. Also wer ein Tweet, eine Insta-Story zum Thema Gaza oder sonst irgendwas, was gerade aktuell ist, Benzin aufgreift, um daraus ein ökonomisches Argument zu Ungunsten eines Autoren zu machen, der verwechselt hier die Arenen. Also der ist einfach unfair unterwegs. Und die zweite Aufklärung von Steffen M war ja, uns in diesem Buch zu sagen, die Leute sind gar nicht so drauf, wie wir glauben. Und das finde ich auch immer interessant, dass Menschen, die diese Art von ökonomischen Canceln unternehmen wollen, immer mit so einem Gedanken rangehen. Naja, ich finde das empörend. Also der Arbeitgeber auch. Nur man kennt ja den Arbeitgeber gar nicht. Man weiß gar nicht, wie die drauf sind. Und man sollte sich da auch hüten davor, Einstellungen über die Einstellung anderer zu haben. Und zu glauben, das wäre jetzt die Einstellung. Sondern das kann auch schiefgehen. So wie zum Beispiel, diesen Fall hatten wir gar nicht besprochen, aber Christian Drosten war ja vor Gericht. Und es ist ja da aus allen Wolken gefallen, dass der Richter nach vier Jahren Corona-Pandemie, Christian Drosten wurde beleidigt auf einem Zeltplatz, plötzlich meinte, es könnte ja sein, dass wir hier einen Wahrheitskern der Beleidigung, Christian Drosten sei ein Menschenverachtender, Kinder schlechter, weil er die Schulen geschlossen hat oder sowas, noch mal nachgehen müssen, also fand so eine Art Corona-Aufarbeitungstribunal vor Gericht stand, weil der Richter meinte, wir müssen das ja noch mal aufarbeiten. So, und der Text in der Zeit schloss dann damit, Christian Drosten würde sich demnächst bei gleichem Vorfall fünfmal überlegen, ob er die Polizei noch mal holt. Was bedeutet, man kann einfach nicht unterstellen oder voraussagen, wie andere Menschen sich verhalten, nicht mal, wenn man denkt, naja, wir gehen jetzt mal vor Gericht, weil da wird ja wohl die Vernunft walten. Nicht mal da greift diese Art von Logik in der Hinsicht, hüte sich vor Annahmen darüber, was der Arbeitgeber denkt, dazu, dass die Beschäftigten da rumrennen.
Und ich finde es auch, ehrlich gesagt, jetzt im Fall Drosten kann ich das nicht beurteilen, ich habe den Fall nicht gesehen, aber ich finde, diese ständige, jetzt Leute verklagen, Abmahnbriefe schicken und so etwas finde ich dekutant. Und ich könnte das auch laufend machen, ich bekomme irgendwelche Kommentare, die wüstbeleidigend sind oder so. Jetzt nicht so, dass ich unter dieser Last zu leiden habe, aber sie kommen, ja. Also ich könnte da bestimmt jemanden beschäftigen, aus der Juristerei, der die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Briefe verschickt. Ich finde das wirklich kindisch, so etwas zu tun. Und das muss man aushalten, wenn man in der Öffentlichkeit steht. Das ist ja bei Drosten so eine Sache, ja, hat sich dann exponiert in der Öffentlichkeit. Das ist noch mal was anderes. Aber Leute, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, die müssen natürlich in ganz anderer Weise Kritik aushalten können. Und deswegen will ich einmal deutlich machen, was wir nicht meinen, wenn wir über Cancel Culture reden und spielen vielleicht da mal einen Clip. Thomas Gottschalk bei seiner, ja, voraussichtlich, wer weiß schon, letzten Wetten-das-Sendung, sagte ja Folgendes.
Inzwischen rede ich zu Hause anders wie im Fernsehen. Und das ist auch keine dolle Entwicklung. Und bevor hier irgendein verzweifelter Aufnahmeleiter hin und her rennt und sagt, du hast wieder einen Shitstorm hergelabert, dann sag ich lieber gar nichts mehr.
Er muss damit leben, dass er irgendetwas sagt und dafür kritisiert wird. Und wenn er irgendeinen Herrenwitz macht, der vielleicht 1997 noch gut funktionierte, aber heute nicht mehr funktioniert, dann wird er das aushalten. Ich will sogar weitergehen. Er wird dafür bezahlt, dass er das aushält. Er exponiert sich und er wird dafür bezahlt, dass er so toll Moderationskarten ablesen kann, sondern dafür, dass er es am nächsten Tag auch von der Presse vielleicht knüppeldick bekommt, weil irgendetwas nicht behakt hat. Das muss man aushalten. Und dass man zu Hause anders redet, als in einer Samstagabendshow, das würde ich mal voraussetzen.
Aber das finde ich eigentlich super lustig an diesem Ding. Jetzt kann ich schon im Fernsehen nicht mehr reden wie zu Hause. So, wir haben ja gesehen, wie er die letzten 30, 40 Jahre im Fernsehen spricht. Begegnet er auch so morgen seiner Familie am Frühstückstisch mit weit geöffnetem Arm und erklärt erst mal, was demnächst zu erwarten ist, die drei Stunden.
Ja, mein Lieber, da ist aber eine schöne Sache.
Das finde ich eigentlich witzig in diesem Bild, dass er da aufmacht.
Ja, also das meinen wir nicht. Und Thomas Gottschalk ist ja jemand, der nicht gecancelt wurde, sondern der beendet jetzt zum siebten Mal wetten das, hat eine RTL-Show, hat einen Podcast, ist ständig irgendwo und hat jetzt noch ein Buch geschrieben über Cancel Culture.
Also, wenn du aus freiwilligen Erwägungen nicht mehr Samstagabends vor Millionen Publikum auftrittst, ist das Cancel Culture. Ich bin da auch dafür allein aus humoristischen Gründen. Das ist vielleicht der letzte Joke, der aus wetten das übrig geblieben ist, dass das als Cancel Culture geht. Ja. Insbesondere, weil er mit Mike Krüger noch einen Podcast macht und sonst auch tausend Anfragen pro Tag. Er darf sich ja äußern, so viel er will.
Ja, jetzt kommt ja sein Buch. Er hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben über Meinungsfreiheit. Man kann darauf...
Ah ja, das bestimmt wie Sarah Ziehn über die Gene.
Ja, wir werden es natürlich nicht lesen, ist er nur gesagt. Nein, das werden wir auf keinen Fall im Salon machen.
Also nicht als gemeinsame Lektüre.
Aber mal gucken, du kannst das gern.
Lektüre 5.
Du hast ja ein paar solcher Bücher schon vorgestellt, du kannst das gern machen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Also das meinen wir nicht, wenn wir von Cancel Culture sprechen. Was aber Cancel Culture meines Erachtens ist, ist genau das, was wir jetzt hören. Marie Agnes Strack-Zimmermann hatte irgendwo einen Wahlkampfauftritt und da waren dann Leute, die irgendwas reingerufen haben. Ich weiß nicht genau, was diese Leute vertreten haben, welche Position, ob die gepöbelt haben, ob das eine fundamentale gute Kritik war. Es ist aber in dem Sinne völlig egal, denn erstaunlich ist Strack-Zimmermanns Reaktion, die wir uns jetzt mal anhören.
Die Führung von Demokratie ist rechner.
Wir beim Maschinenbau und Auto-Zulieferer halten und sie machen mit der gesamten Regierung gerade alle möglichen Arbeitsplätze kaputt.
Sie machen alle möglichen Arbeitsplätze kaputt.
Sie machen die Arbeitsplätze kaputt. Da ist jemand, der im Maschinenbau-Sektor tätig ist. Und jetzt verlangt Strack Zimmermann, er soll doch bitte mal sagen, wer der Chef ist, damit man dann denunzieren kann. Und das ist doch unglaublich, dass das einer liberalen Politikerin unterläuft. Denn das ist ja die liberale Verabredung, dass man sagt, ich habe eine politische Meinung und ich bin aber Angestellter irgendwo. Und das eine hat mit dem anderen erst mal nichts zu tun. Das ist ja auch genau das, was passiert im Supermarkt. Ich kaufe dort irgendwelche Produkte, weiß nicht, wer an der Kasse sitzt, was der gewählt hat, ob der Führer oder gegen den Verbrennermotor ist oder was der von der Ukraine hält, sondern das ist die liberale Verabredung. So funktioniert es überhaupt. Wenn wir erst Gesinnung machen und dann machen wir Handel, dann können wir auf jeden Fall die FDP in Gänze abschaffen.
Also wir werden ja heute in unserem Buch, das wir besprechen, sehr viel Politikwissenschaft, wie sie da liegt, mit Soziologie, wie man auch drüber nachdenken könnte, kontrastieren, wie sie nicht in diesem Buch drinsteckt. Und hier möchte ich noch mal dran erinnern, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, weil ich es wirklich wahnsinnig interessant finde. Rainer Schützeichel, jüngst gestorbener Soziologie-Professor hier in Deutschland und wirklich wahnsinnig guter Lehrer. Der fing ja damals, als ich noch in Bielefeld war, da mal eine Vertretungsprofessur gehabt. Also vor, sagen wir mal, 15 Jahren oder so. Und meinte dort, ja, ja, wir sagen jetzt natürlich immer, die funktionale Differenzierung ist irgendwie der Gipfel der Entwicklung. Also wir haben ein Wirtschaftssystem, Politik. Und dann eben Arenen, da kreuzt man sich nicht. Also nicht so wie sie hier. Ach, Sie möchten ein politisches Argument machen? Dann sagen Sie mir erst mal, wer gibt Ihnen denn das Geld zu leben? Ich möchte mit dir mal reden, so. Ich will Ihnen hintenrum eine reindrücken. Und er meinte damals schon, die funktionale Differenzierung, die also die stratifikatorische, also wir haben so verschiedene Schichten oder Zentrum, Peripherie, irgendwo gibt es einen König und dann alles weitere ist Peripherie. Das ist nicht das Ende der Geschichte, sondern das ist halt einfach nur so ein Zustand der Differenzierung, wie wir sie heute vorfinden. Es kann durchaus durch eine ethnische Differenzierung abgelöst werden. Hatten wir ja schon mal den Versuch, kauft nicht beim Juden, auch wenn es da billiger ist. War ja so das Argument. Und sowas sickert dann doch wieder ein, wenn Demokratien dämmern. Also wenn sozusagen am Ende nicht einfach Umfragewerte umgemünzt werden in ah ja, dann zählen wir heute mal richtig durch, was jeder Einzelne sagt, wenn er zur Wahl geht. Sondern, nee, wir sehen, dass sekundär noch wichtiger ist, dass wir erst mal ethnisch, so wie die AfD jetzt rangeht oder die CDU, so eine Art von, na ja, zu Deutschland gehört eigentlich nur der und der und dann der Islam nur, wenn er sich an die Regeln hält oder wie auch immer, was ja immer bedeutet, wir nehmen dir deine Wahlstimme weg und so. Also Demokratie schön und gut, aber im Supermarkt bitte nur mit Bezahlkarte. Also die ökonomischen Rahmen sind zweitrangig. Erst mal wird nach Ethnie geguckt, ob du hier dahergehörst und bei der Politik dann auch. Also in deren Sicht ist sie hier nicht nur empörend unterwegs, sondern sie dreht auch das Rad der Geschichte zurück. Dafür, dass die Liberalen gerade in einer Fortschrittsampel sind, ist das besonders blöde. Und ein schöner Grundbegriff dafür ist, wir lernen ja heute die Devolution, also das Gegenteil von Evolution. François Retschki hat ja das Wort geprägt, Faltung einfach. Also Sachen entfalten sich und können auch gefaltet werden. Wir sehen hier eine Faltung. Hier wird ein Rad zurückgedreht von ihr.
Und das finde ich katastrophal, wenn das jetzt Einzug hält, also wenn es jetzt darum geht, dass man Angst aufbaut, dass jemand seinen Job verlieren kann. Und ich glaube auch, dass wir das schon die ganze Zeit erleben, gar nicht so explizit ausgesprochen. Wir haben uns ja sehr gewundert und haben ja Precht und Wälze auch gelesen, warum die Berichterstattung über die Ukraine und auch über Corona so gleichförmig war. Es ist eine Angst da, dass man den Job verlieren könnte, wenn man in irgendeiner Weise andere Positionen einnimmt, die nicht gerade mainstream sind. Und da sind wir in einer komfortablen Situation, dass wir das nicht morgen vor der Redaktion noch mal rechtfertigen müssen. Und wenn uns bei Twitter Leute angreifen, ist uns das auch ziemlich egal. Aber das ist etwas, was heute so sehr Journalisten auch prägt. Und junge Journalisten, und ich kenne ja junge Journalisten, die sehr vorsichtig sind oder vorsichtig geworden sind und sagen, das lasse ich mal lieber. Oder sie hoffen darauf, dass irgendjemand, der nicht mehr so viel zu verlieren hat, der schon den alten Vertrag aus den 90ern noch mitzulieft, dass der es dann einmal sagt, dass der sich weiter hervorwagt, damit die anderen so ein bisschen im Windschatten mitgehen können. Damit nicht alles so gleichförmig ist. Das ist das eine, was ich sagen will. Und das zweite, was ich dazu sagen will, was du jetzt gerade ausgeführt hast. Diese Tribalisierung, die da stattfindet jetzt wieder, dass man erst mal die Gesinnung abfragt oder die Zugehörigkeit, die Identität und all das. Das ist etwas, was mich auch wahnsinnig aufregt an dieser BDS-Bewegung, die ja Produkte aus Israel boykottieren will. Und da muss ich ganz klar sagen, das mache ich nicht mit. Sowas finde ich absolut falsch. Ich will sogar sagen, es ist idiotisch. Man kann nicht die Bevölkerung Israels in eins setzen mit der israelischen Regierung, mit der Netanyahu-Regierung und dann alle dafür bestrafen. Ich bin sehr dagegen, deswegen auch sehr skeptisch gegenüber einigen Sanktionsmaßnahmen, die getroffen werden, nicht nur in Bezug auf Russland, sondern generell, ich finde, ein solches in eins setzen, ist absolut falsch. Also nicht nur wegen der deutschen Geschichte, auf die dann immer Bezug genommen wird in der Kritik an BDS, sondern ich finde das grundsätzlich falsch. Und das geht bei mir so weit, dass ich, ich kann es ja hier sagen, auch jetzt in den nächsten Tagen in die Oper gehe und dort Anna Netrebko erleben werde. Ich boykottiere nicht Anna Netrebko, weil Putin einen Krieg führt. Das ist für mich völliger Unsinn. Die Frau wohnte in Salzburg, hat damit nichts zu tun. Was ich aber auch sagen will, ist, dass ich so idiotisch ich BDS finde, es genauso idiotisch finde, dass jetzt ganz viele Demonstrationen, Happenings, Veranstaltungen, Konferenzen nicht stattfinden dürfen beziehungsweise von der Polizei aufgelöst werden, weil dort gewisse Standpunkte vertreten werden, die dem BDS nahestehen.
Möglicherweise.
Möglicherweise. Man weiß das dann alles noch gar nicht, sondern da wird im Vorhinein auch irgendwas schon entschieden. Da wird die Meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt. Ich bin absolut dagegen. Ich bin aber dafür, dass Free Speech herrscht. Ich finde, man sollte eigentlich jetzt Free Speech wirklich ernst nehmen. Und deswegen bin ich auch so enttäuscht, will ich nicht sagen, weil ich nicht allzu viel von Ihnen erwarte, aber ich finde es doch schon erstaunlich. Dass jetzt gerade die Leute, die die ganze Zeit über Cancel Culture geredet haben, wenn irgendwo kritisiert wurde, dass da jemand im Indianerkostüm rumläuft, dass die jetzt völlig stumm sind, wenn es um diese Universitätsproteste, die gewaltsam aufgelöst werden und so weiter geht. Das geht dann auch nicht. Also wenn, dann muss man liberal bleiben. Auch bei den Sachen, die einem nicht gefallen. Anders geht das nicht. Ich will sagen, natürlich darf nicht zu Straftaten aufgeführt werden. Natürlich darf es keinen Judenhass geben, der da artikuliert wird. Und da muss eingeschritten werden. Aber wie man das bisweilen ausgeweitet hat, das finde ich absolut falsch und zerstört die gesamte Diskussionskultur. Und dann sind wir irgendwann nur noch in tribalistischen Kämpfen verquickt mit der finanziellen Komponente. Wer ist dein Arbeitgeber? Du darfst da nicht mehr arbeiten, du da nicht mehr. Dann canceln wir uns alle gegenseitig nur noch selbst. Und deswegen finde ich das alles von Grund auf falsch. Und das wäre auch so eine Kritik an dieser Nancy Fraser, der Philosophin, die da ausgeladen wurde in Köln. Ich hätte die nach Köln an die Uni geholt, dann kann sie aneinander sprechen, ihre Ansichten zu Nahost-Kuntun. Aber dann kann man sie auch dafür kritisieren, wenn sie BDS-Boykotte gut findet. Weil dann würde man sagen, du willst ja auch nicht boykottiert werden. Dann könnte man den Tribalismus ja mal bloßlegen. Das könnte man alles machen. Aber irgendwo scheinen diese ganzen Cancel-Maßnahmen auch dazu zu führen, dass man fast Angst vor sich selbst hat, fast Angst davor hat, dass man nicht in der Lage sei, zu widersprechen.
Ja, also ich finde diese ganzen Sachen, da wir jetzt noch zwei Clips gucken, zum Thema Cancel Culture, wo man es mal exemplarisch durchdiskutieren kann, der Fall ist zum Glück ziemlich runtergedampft. Denn ich würde mich ja ungern so verfangen in einzelnen Empörungsepisoden, wie du sie jetzt thematisch aufgereiht hast, denn ich denke mir irgendwie, Leute einfach modern denken. Es gibt ja so ein paar Prinzipien, die kann man einfach immer als unhintergehbar nehmen, wie zum Beispiel die, also wir haben jetzt schon gesagt, Arenen nicht überschreiten, Ökonomie hier, Politik da. Klar gibt es da Überschreitungen. Also der Alltag ist nun mal ein kompliziertes Geschäft, aber prinzipiell und vor allem analytisch kann man schon mal getrennt daran gehen, wie auch die Trennung zwischen Leistung und Publikumsrollen. Also wenn man im politischen Felde ist, muss man im politischen Felde noch mal unterscheiden zwischen den Wählern und den Gewählten. Klar gibt es immer einen Zusammenhang. Also irgendwer hat ja die israelische Regierung gewählt, aber trotzdem ist die israelische Regierung nicht das israelische Volk, die israelische Bevölkerung, die Freunde Israels auf aller Welt, wie auch immer man das dann da klassifiziert. Hier bei Agnes Strack-Zimmermann, es ist ja noch interessant, dass wir ja eigentlich schon die Liberalen kritisieren, wenn sie irgendwie sagen, du musst aber besonders fleißig sein, um von der Allgemeinheit finanzielle Zuwendung zu bekommen. Wer nennt das denn, wenn es an Fleiß geknüpft ist, einen Lohn für deine Arbeit? Und mit Bürgergeldansprüchen sind wir schon sehr zurückhaltend. So, und wenn sie das jetzt so weit dreht, dass du demnächst nicht nur fleißig, sondern auch noch artig und brav sein musst, dann versteht glaube ich jeder, dass es Kindergarten ist. Ja, also das geht so einfach nicht. Da haut man sozusagen, gerade als Politikerin, sehr vielen Menschen ihre Leistungen, die sie erbracht haben, damit wir in einer modernen Welt leben, wieder in Trümmern. Und wir wollen nicht, dass die Welt in Trümmer gelegt werden, insbesondere nicht im politischen Felde. Deswegen kämpft man ja auch so gegen die AfD und so weiter. Und dann ist es ja nicht sehr sinnvoll, sie selber in Trümmern zu legen.
Und deine Position ist ja genau die richtige seit modernen, weil sonst verliert man sich in tausende Einzelkämpfe. Und der hat aber da das gesagt und so. Ich habe das jetzt auch nur gestreift. Ich muss sagen, ich lese keinen einzigen Artikel mehr dazu, was an der Columbia oder sonst wo stattfindet, weil ich mich nicht da reinfuchsen will. Das hilft mir auch nicht weiter. Ich sehe nur hier schon auf kleiner Ebene, wir hatten dieses Genderverbot in Bayern, wie irrsinnig das ist. Ich würde aber auch sagen, dieser Irrsinn, den wir da sehen, ist nur machtpolitisch umzusetzen, weil man die parlamentarische Macht dazu hat.
Ja, oder halt die Hauheit über die Geschäftsordnung. Dass es nicht mal parlamentarisch demokratisch ist.
Ich will aber auch hinzufügen, und das teilen mir Leute mit, die an Schauspielschulen sind oder waren oder Kunsthochschulen sind. Dort ist auch eine Cancel Culture bisweilen am Werke. Autoren, denen man irgendwas nachsagt oder westlicher Kanon, was auch immer, wo man solche Dogmen plötzlich ausgesprochen hat, von manchen, also nicht die ganzen Schulen, sondern es sind dort einige sehr laute und sehr heftige Strömungen. Und die würden, da habe ich gar keinen Zweifel, wenn die die politische Macht eines Markus Söder hätten, sofort Gesetze erwirken, dass gewisse Autoren oder gewisse Wörter nicht mehr auf der Bühne stattfinden. Das können die nur nicht machen, weil sie nicht die Macht dazu hätten. Aber sie würden es am liebsten und mit welchem Furor, die an diesen Kunsthochschulen dort zugange sind. Da mache ich mir auch gar nichts vor. Also das sind auch nicht unsere liberalen Freunde dort.
Die Kunst, und wir nähern uns hier diesem Cancel Culture-Fall, ist ein besonderes Pflaster. Es ist ein Beruf, den man nur mit Leidenschaft ausfüllen kann. Und die Konkurrenz ist unglaublich groß. Also Scott Galloway weist immer wieder darauf hin, ja, man kann durchaus gerne Schauspielerin, Influencer oder was auch immer werden wollen. Aber anders als im Feld der Bäcker, Lehrer und so weiter, kommen dort nicht 99 Prozent derjenigen, die das Ansehen haben, unter, sondern nur 1 Prozent. Also das ist ein hart umkämpftes Ding. Und dann haut man natürlich, egal mit welchen Mitteln, alle raus. Weshalb wir da auch sagen, ja, tobt euch auf der Bühne aus, aber ihr kriegt hier keine Macht.
Wo du das gerade noch mal so beschreibst, das ist so lustig, weil jetzt der deutsche Filmpreis ja bald verliehen wird. Und der hat jetzt, ich glaube, ein halbes Dutzend Hosts, um die Diversität abzubilden. Und dann wurde auch gesagt, der deutsche Film steht für Diversity und Demokratie. Und dann dachte ich so, nee, also Filmproduktion ist so mit das undemokratischste, überhaupt die Filmbranche ist so mit das undemokratischste, was ich mir überhaupt vorstellen kann. Also mir fällt gar nichts anderes ein, was so sehr ungerecht, so hierarchisch ist, wo es so wenig darum geht, dass Chancengleichheit herrscht. Geschweige denn eine wirkliche ökonomische Gleichheit. Nein, es sind die, man muss das eigentlich schon sagen, 0, 1 Prozent, die wahnsinnig absahen und reich sind und die sind wegen mir auch noch divers. Aber das ist nicht Demokratie.
Ja, manchmal, das ist ja einer der, ich weiß gar nicht, wer ihn gesagt ist, zwar nicht Robert Musel, ich weiß nicht, aber wenn du eine Partei hast, die für die Demokratie kämpft, musst du sie wie eine Armee aufstellen. Du musst also den Code, den du erwirken möchtest, nicht in deine Organisation kopieren, sondern invertieren. Wenn du nicht klar geregelt hast, Angela Merkel sagt, wo es langgeht und der Rest hält sich in Wartestellung, dann hast du eine Linksfraktion und dann war es das mit dem demokratischen Kampf. Also dann bist du einfach 4, 8 Prozent. Das gilt dann im Film auch. Also wenn der Film besonders aufgeklärt, ausgewogen und divers daherkommt, dann weiß man hauen und stechen. Fand in der Manufaktur statt. Gut, die Cancel Culture war Thema beim Heute-Journal am 13. War es wirklich das Heute-Journal oder die Kulturzeit? Wir sehen es gleich. Otfried Preußler soll jetzt gecancelt werden. Krabart ist natürlich das eine, er hat aber noch mehr geschrieben. Und einiges ist in Verruf geraten.
Carolina und Johanna gehen in die 11. Klasse des Otfried-Preußler-Gymnasiums in Pollach südlich von München. Doch sie wollen, dass die Schule so nicht mehr heißt. Die Gründe? Preußler habe keinen Bezug zum Ort und der Name eines Kinderbuchautoren passe nicht zum Gymnasium. Vor allem aber habe Preußler verschwiegen, dass er als Jugendlicher von den Nazis begeistert war. Davon zeuge sein früher Roman Erntelager Geier.
Dass er sich eben generell nicht zu seiner Vergangenheit geäußert hat und auch generell nicht zum Erntelager Geier jetzt genau, das ist ja so, wo wir das Problem sehen.
Erntelager Geier beschreibt autobiografisch und glorifizierend den Ernteeinsatz von Hitlerjungen auf dem Land. Preußler hat den schon lange nicht mehr verlegten Roman 1941 als 17-Jähriger geschrieben. Er hat sich nie zu dem Werk und zu seiner Zeit in der Hitlerjugend geäußert. Dass es dieses Erstlingswerk überhaupt gibt, wurde erst vor neun Jahren bekannt. Lehrer und Schüler des Gymnasiums, die den Namen schon lange loswerden wollten, beschäftigten sich intensiv mit Preußler und kamen zu dem Schluss. Der weltberühmte Kinderbuchautor Tauge nicht mehr als pädagogisches Vorbild.
So, was ist an den Schulen los? Also, ich bin ja sehr wohlwollend den Jugendlichen gegenüber. Mit 17 Jahren, das ist ja hier das Thema, kann man Fehler machen. Wie wir es gerade hören, von den beiden Schülerinnen. Aber in dem Bericht heißt es ja, Lehrer und Schüler, also die Lehrer auch, haben sich mit Otfried Preußlers Vergangenheit beschäftigt. Nun haben wir es hier mit, ich nehme mal grob an, ein bisschen älter als Flagghelfer-Generation zu tun. Da würde ich sagen, ja, da war er vielleicht nicht der Einzige, der geschwiegen hat. Vielleicht war das ein ganz großes deutsches Thema, dass da eine Generation geschwiegen hat. Das hat so einiges noch in dieser längerfristigen Nachkriegszeit bis heute nachwirkt. Und das ist, finde ich, ein ganz tragischen Fall. Schon allein, weil hier in dieser Berichterstattung so deutlich wird, die wollten den Namen eh loswerden. Und die Lehrer haben hier einfach eine Gelegenheit genutzt. Und wie ich jetzt sagen möchte, die Kinder instrumentalisieren. Auf eine ganz fiese Art und Weise. Wir sehen ja in dem Bericht auch, wir hören gleich noch den zweiten Clip wahrscheinlich, gar keinen Lehrer oder eine Lehrerin, sondern nur diese beiden Mädels da gerade. Also in der Ansicht, wir hören mal seine Familie, also Preußlers Familie äußert sich.
Das löste bundesweit eine mediale Empörungswelle gegen die Schule aus.
Wir wurden als rückwärtsgewandt dargestellt, als Verleugner, Cancel Culture. All diese Dinge tauchten auf. Es gab persönliche Beleidigungen gegenüber dem Schulleiter, gegenüber den beiden Lehrkräften, aber auch natürlich gegenüber der Schulfamilie und den Schülern und Schülerinnen.
Man wolle weder Otfried Preußler angreifen, noch den Wert seiner Millionenfachverkauften und in mehr als 50 Sprachen übersetzten Kinderbücher, wie der kleine Wassermann, die kleine Hexe oder Räuber Hotzenplatz-Mehlern, betont die Schule. Doch genau das sei geschehen, kritisiert Otfried Preußlers Tochter.
Man darf nicht leichtfertig einfach so mit mittels 3, 4 Jahren ein 90-jähriges, ehrhaftes Leben versuchen, in die Tonne zu treten. Der Schule hätte es gut getan, wenn sie ein bisschen weniger Scham vorm Mund gehabt hätte und ein bisschen gescheiter hingeschaut hätte, was sie auch ihren Schülern da vermitteln.
Susanne Preußler, die das literarische Erbe ihres Vaters verwaltet und ihr Sohn berichten, dass Otfried Preußler, wie viele seiner Generation, vielleicht auch aus Scham, nicht über seine Zeit in der Hitlerjugend sprach. Doch er habe später seine damalige Faszination für die Nazis als Irrweg bezeichnet.
Bereits in Kriegsgefangenschaft hatte er erkannt, welche mörderischen und totalitären Ideologie er angehangen hat, wie immer da auf den Leim gegangen ist. Das war ein Lebensthema für ihn, das zu bearbeiten. Als Schriftsteller hat er das hauptsächlich literarisch gemacht.
Wie zum Beispiel in einem seiner bekanntesten Jugendromanen Krabatt, in dem Preußler vor der Faszination des Bösen und der Verführbarkeit der Jugend warnt. Inzwischen musste das Gymnasium in Pollach seine Aussage widerrufen, dass Otfried Preußler schon mit 17 in die NSDAP aufgenommen worden sei. Was für die Schule als Beweis seiner strammen Linientreue gilt, lässt sich nicht belegen.
Ich habe mittlerweile keine Haltung bzw. die, dass ich finde, dass die Schule den Namen nicht verdient.
Ob sich das Otfried-Preußler-Gymnasium in Pollach tatsächlich umbenennen kann, entscheidet jetzt das Bayerische Kultusministerium. Die 21 anderen Otfried-Preußler-Schulen in Deutschland wollen, zumindest bisher, an ihrem Namen festhalten.
Ja, wir haben keinen Vertreter der Lehrerschaft gehört. Ich möchte gerne anmerken, wenn das passiert, also wenn man im Unterricht Krabatt bespricht und danach Otfried Preußler vorwirft, was auch immer ein überzeugter Nazi damals gewesen zu sein, dann lief da einfach was falsch.
Ja, dann hat man das Berg nicht verstehen wollen und hat sich stattdessen auf den Autor gestürzt. Im Prinzip findet hier statt, was wir auch in der kulturellen Berichterstattung immer sehen. Man könnte über literarische Texte sprechen. Ach, da müsste man sie lesen, müsste sich über die literarische Form Gedanken machen, vielleicht auch über die Weltanschauung, die Ideologie. Oder man macht so ein Porträt mit dem Autor, was er eigentlich fühlt und ob er gestern noch seine kranke Mutter besucht hat.
Das literarische Leben.
Das ist es, was eigentlich heute vorwiegend stattfindet. Die Konzentration, die Fixierung, muss man sagen, auf den Autor und da jetzt noch mal zu wühlen. Es ist ja gerade wenn dies hier zutage befördert wurde, eigentlich ein guter Name für eine Schule, weil sie beide Seiten zeigt. Weil sie die Verführbarkeit zeigt und dann die nachträgliche Kritik an der Verführbarkeit. Also in gewisser Weise muss man ja eine Schule nicht nur nach Helden benennen, sondern gerade nach den Helden mit den kleinen Fehlern, also wie im aristotelischen Drama. Das sind eigentlich die interessanten Figuren. Die sind nämlich nicht übermenschlich groß, sondern die sind allzu menschlich, erschreckend menschlich. Und daran ließe sich vieles erklären und so viel ableiten. Aber das ist ja sinnbildlich schon für eine Diskussion, die wir jetzt seit Jahr und Tag haben. Und ich würde auch jetzt nicht zu Übertreibungen neigen und sagen, dort geht jetzt das Abendland unter.
Ich schon.
Nur weil die die Schule umbenannt haben. Ich würde aber sagen, es ist ein klarer Ausdruck einer neuen Tribalisierung und einer neuen Entliberalisierung der Gesellschaft, die am Ende dazu führt, dass man nur noch in Graben kämpfen, statt nur noch in Graben kämpfen, sich aufhalten wird. Und man wird sich nicht mehr mit dem Substanziellen, zum Beispiel mit dem literarischen Werk, auseinandersetzen.
Also ich möchte das schärfer formulieren. Für mich ist das wirklich ein Untergang des Abendlandes, denn dieser Otfried Preußler hat nicht nur, dafür kennen wir ihn ja, wirklich tolle und auch wichtige Bücher geschrieben, sondern er hat überhaupt erst einmal geschrieben und zudem als 17-jähriger. Er eignet sich dadurch besonders gut für den Namen einer Schule, auch wenn die da jetzt kommen mit, ich bin 17, ich will nicht, das ist ein Kinderbuchautor, ich habe ja auch ab 13 Jahre keinen Kindergeburtstag mehr gefeiert, sondern einen Jugendlichen Geburtstag, ich habe auch kein Kinderzimmer mehr. Ja, aber mit 17 Jahren hat der Mann ein Buch geschrieben. Er hat über mehrere Seiten einen zusammenhängenden Text formuliert. Das finde ich, ist die primäre Aufgabe der Schule, heute insbesondere.
Wir werden ja gleich über Funktionalen-Analphabetismus reden. Es gibt eine Passage in diesem Buch, die mich so umgehauen hat, dass ich sie schon zwei Freunden vorgelesen habe.
Also wir haben es hier wirklich gerade mit ganz großem Dramen zu tun. Selbst wenn man jetzt irgendwie sagt, nee, Otfried Preußler, ich mag keinen Namen, wenn die Initialien OP sind. Völlig belangloses Argument. Selbst dann würde ich sagen, nein, als jemand, der Texte schrieb, zudem in jungen Jahren und dann das Besondere, wie wir das heute nicht mehr haben. Es gibt nirgendwo in Deutschland einen 17-Jährigen, der in der Lage wäre, 100 Seiten Text zusammenhängt zu schreiben. Einfach nur durch die allgemeine Verblödung, die hier stattfindet. Ja, man schafft ja nicht mal ein Video zu produzieren, das länger als drei Minuten dauert. Und von daher halte ich das für ganz dramatisch, was hier passiert. Insbesondere, dass ein Fernsehteam dahin fährt und kein Lehrer in der Lage ist, sich vor Kamera zu äußern. Die wurden hier auch gefragt und die haben einfach nicht geantwortet. Und das halte ich für einen unglaublichen Vorgang, dass dann plötzlich so zwei Schüler vorgeschickt werden. Also das ist für mich Untergang des Abendlandes.
Ja, unter der Prämisse gestehe ich das zu. Also wir halten fest, es gibt Cancel Culture und zwar von allen möglichen Seiten und auch von sich eigentlich sehr widersprechenden Seiten. Und deswegen hier das Credo von Stefan Beachten modern sein.
Einfach mal modern sein jetzt.
Lieberalität zulassen, denn alles andere sorgt nur für solchen Mumpels und sorgt dafür, dass unglaublich viel Zeit gefressen wird mit so einem Kram. Stattdessen, da wurde jetzt auch schon wieder viel Gehirnschmalz verwendet, hätten die vielleicht einfach mal noch einen zweiten Otfried Preußler-Roman lesen können. Vielleicht hätte das weitergeholfen oder sie hätten diesen Roman über die Hitlerjugend ja jetzt mal gelesen mit einer anderen Perspektive, nämlich der heutigen, der Nicht-Hitler-Jugend-Anhänger und sagen, was steht da eigentlich drin? Was erfahren wir möglicherweise Gespenstisches über uns? Nämlich der Rechtsdruck ist ja nun das große Thema. Und ich würde sagen, auch an diesem Gymnasium werden viele Leute sein, Schüler sein, auch Lehrer vielleicht, die sagen, auch die AfD ist eine Alternative. Vielleicht sollte man gerade deshalb mal da nachlesen und ein bisschen gefeit werden vor diesen Verführungsangeboten, die der Faschismus einem bietet.
Also wenn man eine Schule, recht großes, modernes Gebäude, ich würde mal sagen mindestens 800 Schüler, die fällt unter die Kategorie, wenn man die wählen ließe, würden die mit verfassungsgebender Mehrheit, ich habe keine Ahnung, wen ich wählen soll, AfD oder CDU wählen. So, das ist die, das muss man jetzt eins plus eins mal durchrechnen, anstatt den irgendwie noch die Texte auszutreiben.
Vielleicht ist Otfried Preußler nicht das größte Problem. Wir gehen jetzt so langsam in den Salon über, wir werden das Buch Demokratie-Dämmerung, eine Kritik der Demokratie-Theorie von Veith Selk besprechen. Und ich sage gleich, dass dies eines der wichtigsten Bücher ist, das wir je im Salon besprochen haben.
Ich widerspreche.
Ich bin wahnsinnig begeistert davon. Ich bin auch erschüttert über die Diagnosen, kann Ihnen aber auch nichts entgegenstellen. Ich finde es wirklich ein sehr wichtiges Buch. Wir müssen darüber reden. Außerdem gibt es von mir einen Roman, den ich vorstelle, von einer niederländischen Autorin Fienn, Feldman Xerox heißt der. Dann geht es um dieses große Verfahren zwischen Pendrian Random House und Schuster. Die wollten ja kooperieren als Verlage. Und dann gab es natürlich dort ein Verfahren. Und diese Akten sind ja alle publiziert. Und die hat jetzt eine Bloggerin sich mal alle durchgelesen und hat jetzt abgeleitet, was heißt das eigentlich für die Buchbranche in den USA, aber in gewisser Weise auch für unsere Buchbranche. Und das ist so unglaublich. Auch was Interessantes noch zu den Büchern der Obamas. Also das ist ein unglaublicher Text. Dann habe ich mir den Gaming-Report angesehen. Unsere Hörerin Anna Katharina hat mir den geschickt. Und da sieht man eigentlich Ähnliches, so eine Tendenz zu wenigen Big-Playern und auch zum Monogaming. Also man spielt nur noch ein Spiel. Außerdem etwas zum EGH-Urteil, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung anbelangt. Da gibt es etwas Neues, was auch nicht gut aussieht. Und es geht um die Berliner Thinktanks zur Außenpolitik, die irgendwie alle so voneinander abschreiben.
Da hat sich ein Muster entwickelt, wollte Katharina Saalfrank beim Blick ins Kinderzimmer sagen. Wir lesen, nachdem ich dir was die Sachen, die ihr beschreibt, nicht widerspreche, aber bei den Schlussfolgerungen auf jeden Fall, in der Demokratiedämmung lese ich, habe ja angekündigt, Macrons Saubonne Rede. Sie ist verfügbar als französisches PDF. Ich habe gesagt, ich kann sie ja per Dieb L übersetzen. Das habe ich auch getan. Es war aber kein schönes Leseerlebnis, denn ein PDF zu übersetzen heißt, der Text muss gleich gesetzt sein. Aber wenn die Buchstaben andere sind, rauscht das manchmal drüber und drunter. Ich war auch ein bisschen überrascht, dass Dieb L dann mehrere Zeilen auf dem gleichen Platz unterbringt, damit das PDF charaktermäßig bleibt. Also lesen wir alternativ die deutsche Berichterstattung zur Saubonne Rede. Ich werde die Fragmente, die ich von der Saubonne Rede kenne, noch mal kurz einwerfen. Da gibt es vielleicht einen kleinen Kontrast. Die New York Times hat diesen Datenfusionsgroßen die Datenwall aufgeschrieben. Simon & Schuster spielt da auch eine große Rolle. Penguin ist nicht der einzige Interessent, sondern es gab noch andere. Und auch mit anderen Beweggründen. Ben Bernanke hat die Bank of England beraten beim Thema Prognosen, unter anderem zum Thema Inflation. Wir haben ja schon überraschendes gelesen. Dass EZB-Autor und der Chefetage schreiben, vielleicht kann man auch einfach mal sagen, hatten da mal Pech. So ungefähr ist Bernanke auch drauf. Und in Nature ein Text, der anderthalb Jahre, ich weiß nicht wie lange das üblicherweise dauert, da Texte einzureichen, da werden die peer-reviewed und so weiter. Aber wir haben eine ordentlich peer-reviewed und deswegen vertrauen wir ihr große Aufarbeitung global, was hat es mit Ökonomie und Ökologie zu tun? Denn die Welt hat ja gesagt, 1, 5 Grad Ziel, na gut 2 Grad Ziel. Nur auch mit einem 2 Grad Ziel gehen ja Klimaschäden einher. Wie hoch sind die eigentlich, auf die wir uns schon geeinigt haben? Plus wie teuer wäre eigentlich das abzuwenden? Und wie teuer wird es danach? Also es sind wirklich gruselige Zahlen, die hier, ich sag mal so 38 Billionen und sowas, ja? Also große Zahlen kommen dann gleich zur Rede.
Sehr gut, dann besprechen wir jetzt gleich erstmal ausführlich dieses ja ungeheuer böse Buch. Also das finde ich ja wirklich. Wie hier jemand sezieren kann, das ist schon toll. Und dann auch hart zustechen, das ist bemerkenswert. Wir werden darüber reden im Salon. Wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt, dass ihr den Salon abonniert. Das ist über verschiedene Wege möglich. Vor allem präferieren wir Steady. Das ist ein deutsches Unternehmen. Dort sind auch alle Salons von Anfang an, von 2020 an, Januar 2020 hochgeladen. Bei den anderen kam das ein bisschen später erst. Wir empfehlen einfach, auf die Neuen Zwanziger-Seite zu gehen. neuenzwanziger.de. Dort findet man den Button, kommt dann zu Steady und kann das Paket buchen, das man gerne haben möchte. Wir freuen uns über diese Unterstützung. Es ist jedenfalls ganz simpel. Es gibt so gut wie nie Rückfragen, wenn irgendjemand das abonniert. Also alle fünf Monate kommt eine E-Mail, wo jemand fragt, ich habe den RSS-Feed nicht gefunden. Aber es funktioniert immer. Man kann den Podcast dann überall hören, so wie man ihn sonst auch hört. Wenn man aber lieber über Apple bucht, dann ist das auch möglich. Ist ein bisschen teurer, weil Apple ja immer noch seine 30 Prozent haben möchte. Das kann man auch machen. Dann kann man direkt bei, was ist das dann? iTunes oder wie heißt das?
Es war früher iTunes. Es ist einfach die Podcast-App. Es ist eine eigenständige App.
Da kann man dann das dazubuchen. Wer bei Patreon schon ist, kann das dort auch machen. Das ist die einzige und zugleich beste Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen.
An dieser Stelle will ich mal darauf hinweisen, es gab Hinweise von Hörern. Einige meiner Podcasts sind ja höher finanziert im Sinne von auf freiwilliger Basis und so weiter. Steady, also stabil. Und da gab es einen Tweet, der wahrscheinlich einige Hörer Ansinnen aufgreift mit der Frage, Stefan hat schon wieder keinen Präsentator für einen Fernsehpodcast vorgelesen, ist er denn in der Existenz gefährdet? Und das kann ich für einen Fernsehpodcast in Aufwachen natürlich nicht sagen. Aber das neue Zwanziger-Modell funktioniert hinreichend gut. Wir müssen uns keine Sorgen machen darum, dass irgendwie im nächsten Monat wir unser Geld anders verdienen müssen oder so. Und vielleicht sollten wir es auch mal empfehlen, wenn jemand die Idee hat, einen Podcast zu machen. Denkt doch das Paywall-Modell gleich mal mit. Denn wir beide haben damit gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Man hört immer häufiger so Podcasts, wo so ein bisschen gebettelt wird, und hier, und dann wird nochmal so was versucht oder so. Einfach mal eine Paywall einführen und mal gucken, wie weit es führt. Wir können es wirklich sehr empfehlen.
Ja, man braucht dann natürlich ein Konzept für ein sinnvolles Zusatzangebot. Das ist bei uns der...
Streit über den Buch wäre schon ganz gut.
Also, dass man nicht jetzt... Also, wir raten dringend davon ab, weil das dann auch manche anbieten so Sachen. Und dann bekommt jeder noch ein Grußkärtchen vom Podcast-Source und so was.
Keine extra Arbeit.
Also, das ist ja auch Unsinn, weil es soll ja wirklich darum gehen, dass der Podcast erweitert wird und dass hinter der Paywall mehr Podcast geboten wird. Und jetzt braucht jetzt nicht noch jemand das Lieblingsrezept für Marmorkuchen von Stefan, glaube ich. Und wenn, dann kannst du das ja mal gratis rumsenden.
In dem Fall wäre das die Donauwelle natürlich, die uns ja Schnee mit dem Kuchen heißt.
Also, insofern muss man sich auch keine Sorgen machen, weil das auch schon mal kam, dass wenn wir uneins sind, dass damit der Podcast gefährdet ist.
Wir veranzeln uns dann.
Weil wir ja im Salon öfter uneins sind, vielleicht sogar als Vor- der Paywall. Heute wird das so sein, das gefährdet dann nicht den Podcast. Denn dieser Podcast heißt ja auch Die Neuen Zwanziger und die sind ja noch lange nicht vorbei. Das heißt, es wird noch viele Salons und noch viele reguläre Podcasts geben. Und keine Sorge, wir machen weiter.
Ja, wir freuen uns einfach nur, wenn ihr dabei seid. In der Hinsicht hier die Einladung. Wir gehen jetzt in den Salon. Kommt gerne mit. Bis gleich.